hello Friday it is in fact Friday I'm
walking to the beach in Costa Rica TGIF
do you like walking you look real
natural at walking if you don't know
afraid to areas look back at the things
that have happened to me this week and
blog form so let's look back on some of
the things like this thing nailed it
hello we are out on the street shooting
photos for a very fun new project yeah
that's the committee of Wonderful's yeah
happy Saturday I just ran face-first
into that door back there looking at my
phone and not paying attention so kids
pay attention
[Music]
it's day 2 of shooting photos for fun
things with Robin shoots we this is
happening this is happening and those
are happening your head
I can't look at myself so the shoot that
we're doing took a turn and every time I
do this just makes me giggle like these
people can't even handle it
don't mind me just driving home after a
long day at work we shot some really
amazing photos today courtesy Robin
shoots Scott she's so awesome at photo
taking at Robin shoots on social media
and when DJ Diaz did this to me and now
I'm driving in a car in Los Angeles like
some books happy Sunday hello it is
Monday not morning it's almost noon and
noon means it's not morning anymore
I'm headed to the great show house we
are shooting two field pieces today for
future episodes which I'm really excited
about because we are shooting them with
glozell and John Green this has been the
most fun part of this show has been
giving to shoot with fellow youtubers
that are friends and people that I
haven't seen for a really long time it's
just really cool to be like hi this
traditional media thing gave me a thing
in there letting all of us be part of
this thing and let's do a theme also
John Green good he just had like the
greatest night
at the MTV Movie Awards holding their
stars one for best movie and shailene
woodley one for best female actress I
just watched the clip from a her
thanking John Green in her speech and
it's just such a beautiful speech and
they cut to John in the audience with
his wife and he's crying and I was like
hah now less than 24 hours later come
over to my house and be a real speaking
and he has agreed because John Green is
a complex wonderful simple beautiful
human being
yay John Green is here and we just shot
our bit how do you feel about it is this
for snapchat no this is for friary oh
nice it was really fun you're so funny
and it's really you make everything easy
this is a very complimentary human being
it's true he's very great it's gonna be
really great bits coming to the show
this Friday 1:00 10:30 on e following
the soup yay go follow John Green on all
the social medias you know how to do it
already
good morning it's Tuesday happening I am
about to go over to the gray steel house
to work on the creative for episode
three and then I'm going to go listen to
my dog scratch her body but then I'm
going over to James Corden I'm gonna be
on The Late Late Show with James Corden
tonight and with Jon Cryer and Frieda
Pinto
yes that's her name for you to pinch oh
the girl from Slumdog Millionaire who I
think is insanely beautiful so can't
wait to feel insecure again here's the
fun thing about having a television show
is that people write articles about
the ratings of the TV show people care
about YouTube's view accounts and that
sort of thing
I've always tried to like not really
care about that I doubt it's just really
funny to me to read these articles like
here's why I'm headline planet it says
ratings II the grace Helbig show Rises
in week two no the second episode of the
new e-series the grace Helbig show did
not achieve significant week over week
improvement it did not establish itself
as anything approximating a hit Fridays
grace Helbig did however best
the premiere episode in both adults 18
to 49 and total viewership given the
nature of the program the standards of
the network and the time slot no one was
expecting monster ratings for the new
talk show and while it is unclear
whether this show is thus far performing
at or above or below the bar anticipated
by E the show does deserve credit for
enjoying improvement in the second week
ratings are up but definitely not it and
no one thought it would be
[Music]
it said coming up with where's our baby
I'll just have it on it's Wednesday it's
a shoot day very exciting stuff and look
Shira Lazar and the people what's
trending send me a gift basket
Oh Thank You Shira and what's trending
that's really sweet of you I'm very
excited today because Miranda sings
coding Ballinger and Jim Parsons are
coming over and it's gonna be a fun day
let's go see how excited everyone is
just sing thrilled thrilled thrilled for
shoot day this is how I prep for the
show you guys are both loading cameras
how embarrassing why didn't you talk to
Greg I hear
two can play this game
two can play at this game someone is a
guest on the show this week
oh it's Jim it is such a good time if
you ever get the chance to come to this
house you should come what a way to end
a video clip I'm trying to are you
watching on the snapchats yes I want to
see what I gotta understand so I'm
trying to ignore like stories well I
figure that out
Chester's birthday he has no idea
[Music]
hey guys if it's Thursday night and I am
in Costa Rica right now I'm on very very
mini vacation a few days away from LA to
do this much work as I do it in LA but
in a different place I've had a second
year to reflect very very briefly on the
small amount of time that we've spent
suiting the grace Helbig show you don't
know I have a TV show on E that just
started it's called the grace Helbig
show it's on Friday nights on E at 10:30
p.m. following the soup and you should
watch it because I think you'd like it
if you've made it this far in this video
god bless you you deserve to watch the
television show wow this view is
beautiful look at this this is what
we're happening upon right now holy moly
well there you go there was a look back
in my way I hope that you enjoyed it
don't forget to subscribe so that videos
come to you instead of you having to go
to them and like this video if you
enjoyed any of it and leave a comment
down below telling me if you watch the
grace Helbig show Friday at 10:30 on e
what did you think
I don't know have you been farting you
can't avoid it
have you been farting you cannot avoid
it have you been frightened no don't
lick my leg like nothing's happened
have you been farting oh now you're so
tired
have you been farting oh okay